foreign
let's go to Alyssa now in Sacramento
California Alyssa how can we help
yeah you know my name is Alyssa thanks
for having me on the show just wanted to
ask you a question regarding my husband
and I we just found out that we're eight
weeks pregnant with our first child yay
it's unexpected but it's a joyful
blessing I wanted to see if we can still
our goal was to purchase a house wanted
to see if we could still do that while
preparing for a baby financially as well
as living on one income potentially okay
so where are you guys at financially do
you have any debt
what about down payment
down payment I have 500.
500 basically we put it
500 because we put it on hold while my
husband finishes student teaching where
he's teaching full-time for free to get
his credential which he should have at
the end of June okay so what is the goal
for down payment in house purchase
so our goal was to take because we think
that we could do fine with a three
months emergency fund because we never
use it uh we have we plan to build it up
six months which we did then basically
um to get through this period without
using your emergency fund which we've
done by living frugally and then take
three months of our emergency fund and
maybe actually into a down payment fund
um add it to the down payment fund and
just have a three-month emergency fund
and then that would give us eight
thousand dollars now you're in
California I assume this house is going
to be very expensive
so if we had I don't know if you guys I
hear sometimes you guys allow people to
do like five to ten percent down on
their first house
um so 20 per 20 000 would be five
percent down and so if we're doing if
I'm doing like side jobs or something
what's your household income with that
one income
um with the one income it's probably
gonna be 55 grand a year this is a
nightmare looking for a place to happen
Okay how much is this mortgage gonna be
um well we were thinking of getting a
duplex where we could that was our
Global foreign
you're going to be a landlord with a
newborn with your neighbor next door
knocking when the HVAC goes out
yeah I think I think we're trying to
justify the home purchase in California
and the numbers just don't make sense so
here's what I'll tell you I would focus
on continuing to save the down payment
let's have the baby let's see where
we're at financially the five to ten
percent is accurate but it needs to be a
quarter of your take-home pay or less on
a 15-year fixed
and I'm guessing that changes the
numbers drastically
okay to where now all right we need to
find a condo in California
that's way more affordable with more
down payment just to make this work and
renting is not a bad thing to do
especially in this season of your life
with a little one coming in you guys
this is a fun New Chapter let's adjust
to that as George said keep saving you
guys are not going backwards by renting
just be smart